[Musique]
tu
un album mythique de portishead repris
par un orchestre et un collectif de
chanteurs
c'est une des créations du printemps de
bourges cette année quelques heures
avant le concert les artistes sont très
enthousiastes
c'est surtout le fait de retrouver la
scène et puis de la dette dans un projet
collectif avec plein de sensibilité
différente en tant que chanteur de
pouvoir chanter dans des lieux magiques
avec des musiciens avec des cordes et
cuivres moi c'est quelque chose que j'ai
jamais fait donc c'est il ya une
noblesse la dent ou après un nom de live
à la maison sur son téléphone un coup
bah oui ça change absolument tout de
dire qu'on va avoir des vrais visages
ont fait ça en toute humilité face à un
disque aussi monument est aussi dans
cette cathédrale je pouvais pas rêver
mieux je pense
l'occasion pour les spectateurs de
découvrir l'album du groupe anglais
sorti en 1994 ou de le redécouvrir
ça a vraiment respecté l'album c'est
peut-être pas trop sorti du cadre mais
ça fait vraiment du bien c'était
chouette et c'était bien que ce soit la
catégorie 6 voilà c'était formidable
c'était un genre de musique que moi je
connaissais pas trop et donc j'ai
découvert que j'avais découvert
l'allemand bien il ya très longtemps
gelé j'ai fait exprès de pas le
réécouter avant avant de revenir et du
coup c'est comme si je le redécouvre et
eos est vraiment vraiment beau que j'ai
encore encore plein d'émotion une
émotion partagée par les musiciens sur
scène pour un moment unique
le concert n'aura lieu qu'une seule fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]